When Sally was six years old, she contracted a virus that destroyed her heart muscle,...
...rendering her heart virtually useless,...
...and triggering with terrifying speed, multiple organ failure.
She was saved by the recent invention of an artificial heart when her own was failing...
...and the donation of a heart from the family of a 48 - year old woman...
...who had lost her life just as Sally was clinging desperately to hers.
"I know I am very lucky to be alive," says Sally quietly.
"I am so grateful to the family of the woman who died.
I think that agreeing to allow the heart of their loved one to be donated was so kind,...
...and I think about her often."
Now 13, she runs around with a heart that is now 55 years old.
Occasionally she gets out of breath,...
...and in winter her hands and feet become painful...
...which are typical symptoms of someone who has had a heart transplant.
Sally's transplanted heart has already been in her body for nearly seven years,...
...and although she takes anti - rejection drugs every day,...
...her immune system is slowly but surely destroying what it sees as an enemy invasion of her body.
Because of this process, the average life expectancy of a donor heart is around 12 to 13 years,...
...so it is likely that before she reaches 20, Sally may need another heart.
But that's something her family prefers not to dwell on.